[Music]
I'm Michael Dafa and I'm a creative best
way to put it
hey I'm not sure the fire in the booth
exposed me to a wider audience you know
I had hundreds of thousands of followers
like loyal followers before that that's
been following me on the journey I think
yeah with the fire and before me got
when I go in there like I said MC quakes
he already had his balls ready
MC quicksand shakes
do you play about my younger brother
they already had their balls ready you
know there was getting in there to go
and promote their single balance that's
what was out at the moment I think with
Shaq you know in his situation he was
just annoyed that Charlie just wasn't
giving him the shot he wasn't respecting
he wasn't putting respecting his name so
when he went in there he had some balls
prepared but then he was so deep deeply
hurt and you know emotionally tainted by
man like Charles that he just went in
there and just pull everything out there
all his emotions came out and that's
when he said the tingles crap you know
I'm saying cuz he money you wanted
Charlie to understand that bro get me
I'm meant to be here bro you know
some of the bars are prepared before and
some of the balls were just like I said
in the moment of the carrot talks you
got I'm saying cuz if that was me I
wouldn't be saying that you know I'm
saying buddy - AK you don't know what
that is gonna come out of his mouth you
know and that's what happened the fan of
beef
[Music]